la parole est à notre collègue michel
raison pour le groupe l'est républicain
je devais la partie merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues sénateurs
monsieur le garde des sceaux ministre de
la justice
plus de 68 milles c'est le nombre de
personnes détenues actuellement dans les
prisons françaises
cinquante-huit mille 500 c'est le nombre
de places une surpopulation carcérale
évalué à près de dix mille détenus une
densité qui peut arriver jusqu'à 120%
dans 93 établissements le nombre de
matelas au sol augmentée de 50% en un an
vêtue surpeuplée nos prisons sont
régulièrement dénoncées par les
instances européennes parmi les pires
d'europe les violences augmentent à
l'intérieur des prisons le taux de
suicide est deux fois plus élevé que
celui de la moyenne européenne
tout ceci ne fait que contribuer à
l'aggravation du mal être bien connue
des personnels pénitentiaires sitôt
entré en fonction votre gouvernement a
pourtant annulé la programmation votée
en mars 2012 de 24 mille places de
prison à l'horizon 2017
le financement le financement ce vote en
année après année en crédits de paiement
parce que vous allez me répondre que
c'était pas financé
trop ambitieux peut-être peut-être mais
quand on observe les chiffres du
ministère de la justice
on est passé de 57 1200 places en
janvier 2012 à 58 mille cinq cents
aujourd'hui ça veut dire que vous n'avez
créé que 1325 places supplémentaires
et pendant ce temps les conditions de
vie indignes s'aggrave
tant pour le personnel pénitentiaire qui
est à bout de force que pour les détenus
je rappelle aussi que votre prédécesseur
a fermé des maisons d'arrêt comme celle
de lure en haute-saône parfaitement aux
normes avec un motif fallacieux et
contestable monsieur le ministre
allez vous enfin relancer un plan de
construction plus ambitieux de places de
prison n'ont pas nouvelle mais bien
supplémentaire pour vous répondre la
parole est au garde des sceaux jean
jacques urvoas police de la justice et
pour 2
merci monsieur le président je crois que
j'aurais d'ailleurs pas besoin de
répondre en deux minutes puisque ma
réponse pourrait tonnerre en trois
lettres
monsieur le sénateur la réponse est oui
vous me demandez s'il faut construire
des prisons oui il faut construire des
prisons
combien faut-il en construire et bien je
vous propose que nous en reparlions au
mois de septembre pour une raison très
simple je pourrai annoncer n'importe
quel chiffre
j'ai d'ailleurs lui que beaucoup
annoncent et 10000 20000 30000 j'ai
compté je crois que depuis que je suis
garde des sceaux j'ai reçu 25 courrier
de parlementaires me demandant des
établissements pénitentiaires le
président retailleau est allé en vendée
pour me dire la roche-sur-yon fontenay
cristaux quatrième monsieur béchu m'a
parlé de la prison de trélazé appelé de
manière urgente aussi qu'indispensable
le lamentin en guadeloupe
je pourrais parler j'en ai parlé que
françois baroin cette semaine de la
prison de lavaux parce que nous allons
en plus fermé clairvaux partout on me
demande des prisons donc vous voulez
vous les la réponse oui nous en
construirons en soldes nous enfermerons
parce qu'il faut aussi en forme
lorsqu'elle vous vétuste hier j'étais à
agen à l'école nationale de
l'administration pénitentiaire salué la
plus grande promotion de pénitence de
personnel pénitentiaire depuis 1958 ils
étaient 7 188 l'année prochaine monsieur
le sénateur nous recruterons 2500
personnel de surveillance
donc évidemment nous supprimons ici des
établissements quand ils sont vêtus
c'est le cas de clairvaux nous
traiterons évidemment avec toute
l'attention qu'il mérite
les personnels qui servent à clairvaux
mais nous ouvrirons la vo 520 places
nous ouvrirons une prison dans votre
département je ne peux d'ailleurs pas
vous dire la capacité puisqu'il ne faut
pas toucher aux prisons qui existe celle
de vesoul par exemple à laquelle je sais
que vous êtes attachés mais oui nous
creuserons nous construirons des prisons
merci à paroles deux secondes seulement
deux secondes
monsieur le président pour vous dire
monsieur le ministre que vous nous avez
donné un certain nombre de chiffres de
ce qu'il fallait faire mais ça n'excuse
pas ce que vous n'avez pas fait
oh